Hello everybody and welcome back to the
channel. Today we'll be talking about
Uber. Now some of my friends like to
call me an Uber driver because I can
comfortably fit three riders in my back
seat. But nonetheless, today we'll be
talking about the architecture of the
application itself. So let's go ahead
and get into it. Uber is a ride hailing
app. When I want to ride, I enter my
pickup and drop off location. From
there, the app asks drivers around me if
they're interested in participating.
Once I'm matched with a driver, I can
see the driver's location. Once I enter
the driver's car, he'll take me the rest
of the way. Personally, I always try to
get myself in a comfortable white van.
For the sake of this video, we're mainly
going to focus on a small subset of the
functionality that's in the Uber app.
Firstly, we want a potential passenger
to be able to request a ride. Next, we
want to send this ride request to nearby
drivers with the purpose of ultimately
generating a match between rider and
driver. Finally, we'll need to show the
rider and driver each each other's
locations until the ride commences.
Let's add in one more non-functional
requirement. A user should not be able
to request multiple rides at a time.
There are a lot of aspects of Uber that
we're not going to cover in this video.
These include route generation, ride
pricing, algorithms, reviews, and much
more. According to some online
estimates, Uber has 200 million
potential riders and 10 million active
drivers in their force. Keep in mind
that Uber basically always needs to keep
track of the location of drivers so they
can be matched to nearby riders. Since
these are cars, their location can
actually change pretty quickly. That
means we should be having these drivers
pinging our servers with their location
every few seconds. Even if it doesn't
take us too much storage to store the
location of each driver, the actual load
for millions of pings per second to a
server is likely too much for a single
box. We're going to have to do some work
to scale this out horizontally. The
first thing that we'll discuss when
talking about Uber is how to request a
ride. At a high level, the passenger is
going to pass in an address for their
starting location and an address for
their destination. As we discussed in
our previous video, there are many
different APIs that can help us convert
these two coordinates separately. There
are many APIs to figure out the path to
get from point A to point B, notably
Google Maps. We could use a very simple
calculation on route distance and
estimated time to provide the user with
a price quote. In reality, Uber is going
to be looking at supply and demand in
order to generate a ride price. Once a
user asks for a ride, we should persist
that information to a database. If we
instead decided to cache this
information on a server, we'd expose
ourselves to two failure scenarios. The
first is that a user could request
another ride on a separate server. The
other is that the server could fail and
the user's ride requests would just be
lost. While you could choose to attempt
to map a user to a single server, it
adds a bunch of complexity in the face
of server failures. And it feels like we
should just put this application state
in a persistent database where we don't
have to worry about losing it. Let's
consider the schema of the rides table.
It should have a ride ID, a start
location, an end location, a creation
timestamp, a status, which could be
requested, claimed, active, complete, or
canceled. We probably also need a
passenger ID here, as well as a driver
ID, which can be filled out when the
ride is claimed. We also likely want an
auxiliary table known as active
passenger ride, which allows us to track
the current ride that a passenger is a
part of. This will just point to a
single object in the rides table. The
reason that it's useful to have this
denormalization is that we'll also
eventually need drivers to be able to
track the rides that they're linked to.
It would be very hard to maintain an
index on driver ID and rider ID on the
same table, which is horizontally
scaled. We could use something like
change data capture, but that introduces
a bit of latency, which we likely don't
want here. Let's summarize our ride
requesting flow. A user gets a ride and
passes in a latitude and longitude for
their pickup point. The first thing we
do is check whether they already have a
ride request out there. If so, the
application server acts based on the
state of the existing ride object. Maybe
we have to keep searching for a driver
for the ride or maybe we have to start
sending the user's location to a paired
driver. If not, we create it by first
adding an entry to the active passenger
ride table and then adding one to the
rid's table itself. At this point, we
can now start searching for a driver.
Notice how we're performing our two
rights sequentially. Doing so allows us
to avoid a potentially slow distributed
transaction. That being said, we want to
be pretty careful about the ordering
here. If we write to the rid's table
first, we could have a situation where a
row is added to the rides table, but
never to the active passenger table.
Then, we could match our passenger with
the driver, and if the passenger all of
a sudden connects to a new server, they
wouldn't know about their claimed ride.
Using the order shown in the diagram
ensures that a passenger will be
guaranteed to track any ride that is
created for them. Even if the right to
the rides table fails, it's totally
fine. The passenger will see that
there's no corresponding ride object for
their row in the active passenger ride
table and realize there's been an error.
When looking for a potential driver, we
basically need to do the following.
First, consider all drivers in the
vicinity of the pickup point. Then
prioritize a couple of the closest ones
and notify them about the ride request.
If nobody accepts, keep sending
notifications to more drivers. Finally,
when one driver accepts, match them to
the ride and ensure that nobody else can
claim it. These steps imply that we need
to know a pretty critical piece of
information, the locations of all the
drivers. As drivers have their Uber app
open, they should be sending their
location to our back end every few
seconds. Fortunately, cellular devices
have a GPS inside of them, and we can
take advantage of that to send their
latitude and longitude to our servers.
That being said, we also need to store
their locations in a manner such that we
can quickly find a set of the closest
drivers to our potential rider.
Fortunately, we discussed how to do this
in our previous video about Yelp. Just
watch that if you want more details on
this section. To summarize, we can use a
geospatial index. This allows us to
easily find all points within a fixed
distance of our rider. For example, when
Pornhub tells me that there are 100 mils
who are interested in me within a 5 mile
radius, they're clearly using one of
these. Now that we're employing a
geospatial index, we have a list of
potential candidate drivers for our
ride. We can use a short TTL for each
location update. This way, we don't have
to manually expire the prior known
location for each driver. This becomes
especially useful when the driver may be
switching between partitions of our
geospatial index, allowing us to avoid a
distributed transaction. Uber could
choose to contact potential drivers
using many different strategies. They
could send the ride request to one
driver or all of them. In reality, it's
probably somewhere between those two
with our backend server doing a bit of
additional logic to notify a few top
candidates. We probably also want to
check if our candidate is currently
serving rides since that means they have
to get to their destination point before
picking up the next passenger.
If we don't hear back within a few
seconds, we can send the ride requests
to even more candidates.
Sending these actual notifications to
the drivers isn't a trivial detail
either. Each driver doesn't know in
advance that it's going to receive a
ride offer at a given time, so its
device isn't proactively requesting
them. Instead, we need a way to notify
our driver. When it comes to doing
real-time communication between a server
and a client, we've got a few options.
The first is to have the client pull the
server on a loop. This works nicely
sometimes because polling is inherently
stateless and the client can easily
switch over to another server if the one
that they're connected to goes down.
That being said, polling has the
disadvantage of having to add a bunch of
request headers to every single request.
Given the frequency of requests with
which drivers send their location to our
servers, this could be significant.
Instead, a persistent connection may be
better for us, which can be established
once.
We now have two options, websockets and
service and events. The former is
birectional, which is actually really
nice for our use case of drivers and
passengers sending and receiving data.
If my backend actually wants to send
data to a driver, it needs to know which
server that driver is connected to.
It'll then first route the data to the
server which forwards it to the driver
over the websocket. We need to maintain
a mapping of this information somewhere.
We can use another database for this
with a table called driver sessions.
This guy has a schema of driver ID and
server IP address with the driver ID
being the primary key. If the driver
connection gets broken and reestablished
on another server, we'll overwrite the
previous session. When a driver accepts
a ride, two things need to happen.
First, the driver needs to note down the
fact that they've accepted it. Second,
we need to prohibit anybody else from
claiming this ride. We accomplish the
first by introducing the driver active
rides table. It looks very similar to
the passenger active ride table, except
a driver can be matched to many
different rides at once. After we add a
row there, we'll update the
corresponding row in the rides table as
long as it has a null driver ID. Like
before, we can update our driver active
rides table before the main rides table
to avoid a costly two-phase commit.
We've already gone through how the
driver likely wants to be connected to
our backend via websocket. That being
said, passengers should do the same.
This is because after a passenger
requests a ride, it needs to both
receive and request a ton of information
back from the server, such as fetching
the status of their ride requests and
sending their location to the driver.
For passengers to receive information
from other servers, we can do something
similar to what we did for drivers and
introduce a passenger sessions table.
This will be updated when a passenger
establishes a websocket connection and
can be referenced when trying to send
data to a particular passenger ID. When
a passenger and driver are matched, they
need to begin sending their location to
one another. The rider can see the
driver's ID in the ride table and from
there use the driver session table to
figure out which server to forward their
location to. On the driver side, things
are basically the same but opposite. We
first pull in any rides that they're
actively serving or have claimed and
send their location to those servers.
While it isn't pictured in the diagram,
it's also the case that the driver is
still sending their location to the
driver location index since they may
continue to claim requested rides. When
a driver completes a ride, we can first
mark it as complete in the rides table
and then mark it complete in the driver
rides table. This way, both the
passenger and driver will know to stop
sending location updates to one another.
It's time to go through our highle
design one step at a time. One key
tenant I want to emphasize here is
trying to make this a state machine. In
this case, that means I don't want any
of our backend servers to be the source
of truth. If they are, they can fail and
things will be left in an inconsistent
state. Instead, by persisting every
state change to a database, any random
server can pick up right where another
one left off and start doing the same
exact thing. Let's now go through our
full user flow beginning from when a
user makes a ride request. The first
thing that they'll do is establish a
websocket with one of our backend
servers. From there, we'll add the
connection into the user sessions table.
The server will then check if that user
has any outgoing ride requests by
joining the passenger active ride table
with the rides table. If there's a ride
in progress or one that needs to be
claimed by a driver, it can just resume
where things left off. If there are no
inrogress rides for the user, the server
creates one and then begins to search
for nearby drivers. First, the server
fetches a list of close drivers and then
picks a few to notify about the ride
request. If nobody accepts the request
for some time, our server will send the
notification to more drivers. In order
for servers to know how to route these
messages to drivers, we need a driver
sessions table. This gets populated when
drivers establish connection to our
backend. From there, the passenger
server reads the driver sessions table
and routes messages to drivers through a
websocket. This entire time, a driver's
device sends its location every few
seconds to the driver location index.
This ping should expire on its own
fairly quickly. Otherwise, a driver that
closes their app may still be pinged for
potential rides. Let's now imagine that
one of the drivers chooses to accept a
ride proposal. The first thing it will
do is add a row to the driver rides
table which should point to the ride
object. From there, we'll update the
ride row itself, adding the driver ID.
At this point, no other driver can claim
the ride. Our user server should start
getting location pings from the driver
shortly after, letting it know to stop
looking for suitable drivers. Drivers
need to forward their location to all
match passengers. As a reminder though,
even when they're doing this, they must
still ping the location index. To ping
their passengers, we can join the driver
rides with the rides table to get the
user IDs in question and then consult
the user sessions table to figure out
which servers those passengers are
connected to. The passenger server will
also have to forward the passengers
location to their driver. It can do so
by consulting the driver sessions table
and routing that message accordingly. In
my opinion, this video was long enough
and complex enough that we should leave
the discussion of our driver location
index to a separate one. We know that
we're sending this guy millions of
updates per second, but what's the most
intelligent way to horizontally scale it
out? In our next video, we're going to
introduce a new concept, geosharting.
Thanks for sticking around this long,
everybody. Uh, next week we'll be
talking about how to split that location
index right in two. Wish someone would
come along and split me right in two,
but I guess we'll have to wait for
another week. See you all in the next